how likely is a russian invasion of
ukraine well i think as the defense
secretary has said over this weekend
over the last couple of days actually we
have to be realistic about uh with
russia having a hundred thousand troops
now on the roughly on the on the border
there that uh an imminent uh uh
incursion by russia is entirely possible
and that's why we've changed the travel
advice and the advice we've given to uk
citizens who are in ukraine do you think
that the reference to munich is that
helpful and diplomatically sensitive
moment well actually i think what ben
has outlined there is uh given an
explanation that people understand
particularly the context of uh
if people have seen the the the new
movie recently in the sense of in the
run-up to world war ii of course there
was lots of diplomatic work people
thought that was progressing but of
course it turned out not to and i think
what the defense secretary quite rightly
is doing is drawing the comparison of
being clear that there's a lot of
diplomatic work going on obviously both
here in the foreign sector have been in
russia themselves this week
the russian state is saying that it is
not planning to invade but when you then
have a hundred thousand now 130 000 we
estimate troops on the border that would
indicate that there is a possibility of
an incursion so it's that balance and
that decision and that
interpretation of the difference between
what we hope will be a diplomatic
outcome but the realistic possibility
that something much more tragic could
occur but i suppose one might say it's
not that technical to make the
associations with nazis well that's not
the point actually the defence sector
was making it's very clear but what he
was drawing was the comparison between
the diplomatic uh attempts in the run-up
to world war ii and the diplomatic
attempts we're all putting in now we
want to see a diplomatic outcome we want
to see a peaceful outcome to this but we
do have to be cognizant of the fact as
you said quite rightly in the outcome
that the quote by winston churchill is
probably as true today as it was back
then in the context of diplomatic talks
with 130 000 troops sitting right there
on the border with that kind of
accumulation there's always the
possibility and the the ability for
russia to move very very swiftly and
very quickly should it decide to do so
which obviously we hope they won't well
there is a school of thought of course
that says that actually he's not really
going to do this but what he has done
bear in mind that russia is
at best a middle ranking economic power
it's got a lot of armed forces but not
as much as some
but he has achieved
a pretty spectacular strategic victory
already by exposing some deep fault
lines in the west and essentially having
everybody dancing to his tomb
actually i think what he has done is
bring the west nato and the european
alliance together to show that we're not
prepared and nobody should be prepared
to see a a country a democratically run
country have its borders threatened in
that way to be very clear that the world
is not going to put up with that and we
need to see we want to see and we need
to see a diplomatic outcome to this and
a peaceful outcome but putting threats
like that on an independent country is
just inappropriate but he knows that in
truth
we've said that we would not put
soldiers into ukraine
that we
would support them in whatever way we
can but essentially
this is uh another
example of the west's failure to stand
up to russian aggression we can go back
as far as hungary in 1956 czechoslovakia
in 1968. or frankly don't go that back
that far crimea 2014 he's done it before
well it may well be that president putin
is testing the boundaries where he can
go and i think that's why it's been
important that the west and i have to
say the prime minister the foreign
secretary of defense actually the uk as
a whole have been leading the way in
bringing that
alliance together to be very clear to
russia that this is not something we
will tolerate we will we do want to see
a peaceful outcome to this but nato is
very very clear that it is right that a
democratic independent country like the
ukraine is allowed to continue as an
independent democratic country without
this kind of bullying or threats
from a state like russia well there may
be a great alliance but some people will
say that's just an alliance of impotence
well actually no i think at the moment
what we're seeing russia has been said
over the last few days in the meeting
they had with ben wallace that they are
not looking to invade if we can avoid
that and we have a diplomatic outcome
then it will have been successful but i
think it's also right that the west
working together is very clear that
should russia take a different course of
action that there will be repercussions
for that because it cannot be acceptable
that an independent state a democratic
state has that kind of threat put upon
it let alone that kind of incursion
should it happen well let's talk about
the um the the possibility of deterring
him if he's pausing um
you said that the west is united but
it's not entirely right is it for
example we know that the eu uh
bank eu's banks have an exposure to
russia of over 60 billion dollars that's
four times
uh the exposure of american banks so the
americans can afford to make threats but
the eu may be more cautious and surely
that is actually what mr wallace is
talking about that our eu partners may
be a bit less willing
than the united states to take the tough
uh deterrent steps uh uh against mr
putin and his allies by cutting off
their supplies to money and so on well
obviously we're not in that position yet
so we'll see what the the outcome is
well no i mean that's interesting
already why aren't we taking steps
already to put to squeeze on him well no
trevor we've been very clear we will
bring in more sanctions that's one of
the repercussions there will be my first
question why are we waiting
we already have some sanctions against
russia already we've already taken the
power in the last week or so with the uh
statutory instrument in parliament to
allow the uk government to put more
sanctions in place that i spent uh most
of last week in the united states
predominantly on northern ireland
business for the uk government but what
is very clear the united states are
absolutely unified in this approach to
ensure that we do not see an incursion
and should russia take that kind of
activity that there will be
repercussions and that's one of the
things we've been very clear with russia
about and to be fair serve our partners
across europe as well well you know our
own parliament
hasn't been very um
hasn't been very convinced
of our uh fortitude in this um the
intelligence security committee
all 18 months or more ago said
russian influence in the uk is the new
normal successive government have
welcomed the oligarchs and their money
with open arms providing them with a
means of recycling illicit finance
through the london laundromat and
connections at the highest levels with
access to uk companies and political
figures now look we've been saying for
years now we're going to clamp down
actually
russian billionaires are still whacking
their money through london's banks we
haven't actually done anything to hurt
putin
well i disagree with that i have to look
before i was in this role i was the
security minister and one of these i
know without going into this kind of
areas that i can't really talk about in
terms of security intelligence we as a
country not only do we already have
sanctions against russia in place
actually is a country where i think we
are in a position where we've done
phenomenal work over the years so that
we're not that kind of thing you know we
are an attractive place for the world's
money and the world's businesses to
invest and to trade that's a good thing
for the city of london but we do have
things in place with this unexplained
wealth orders and a whole range of other
measures that mean that we are somewhere
that deters the kind of illegal activity
uh that you refer to and i have to say
if you look at some of the famous names
around the world that people talk about
in terms of that kind of russian
activity this is not a country that they
spend time in it's not a country they
come to and i do think we have those
measures in place to protect our
institutions well they don't have to
come here they can you know they can
stay in monaco or whatever it is but
their money is here and i i'm sure i'm
curious about this because um
liz trusts when she was sitting where
you are sitting a week or two ago said
to me that you're going to introduce new
legislation that will uh give you
greater powers to confiscate
the assets of these people and put
pressure on putin if actually we've been
so successful so far why do you need new
legislation well because look that's
actually quite simple we yes we have we
have things like as i say unexplained
wealth orders is one of the tools in our
army that we can use and the security
services the police services do use that
it's been very successful it's actually
one of the things that ben wallace
brought him and he was security minister
but we're always looking at how we
reassess as financial markets move as
technology moves you've always got to
keep these things under review to make
sure that you are able to have the tools
that you need to deal with what people
are trying to do it's the same with
fraud and internet activity more
generally these things are always moving
they're always developing and it's right
that our
teams keep that under review and that's
partly why even just last week we've
taken the power to bring in more
sanctions should we need to do so that's
something that the the teams are looking
at at the moment to make sure that if we
need to do that we have the ability to
do it and do it in a way that actually
has impact all right let's talk about
your own response with northern ireland
northern is right now without a first
minister or a deputy first minister
i understand you're just back from
washington where i get that you've been
talking about this to officials there
what were you hoping to achieve in your
trip to america well it was a long
planned trip actually it was around a
range of issues just generally about the
uh and i was in both washington and
boston about the investment that the us
has generally had in northern ireland
business investment which is hugely
important as part of delivering
prosperity and that's part of the peace
process you've seen jobs and
opportunities created and particularly
the burgeoning cyber and uh technology
sector in northern ireland there's huge
u.s interest in that so looking at how
we bolster that to how we do more and
how we develop that but also talking to
our friends and colleagues in the united
states to make sure that they're aware
of our position on the northern ireland
protocol the u.s have a huge interest in
what happens in northern ireland their
uh emotional attachment their
involvement in the good friday agreement
they've been a key player in northern
ireland over the years and make sure
they understand what are the problems
with the north island protocol and what
is it we envisage as a way through this
well dude you talked about the emotional
uh involve
attachment of the americans and the
president biden himself of irish
heritage was clear in his election
campaign that um there would be no trade
deals until the protocol issue is sorted
out um
were you able to get them to budge on
that
well actually the uh secretary of state
for international trade anne marie
terrell is going to the u.s just in the
next few weeks to have to continue the
discussions about trade deals one of
these i do find the usc us is a hugely
important obviously one of their
strongest allies in the world they're
keen to trade with us to look at what
more we can do around global trade and
trade between the uk and the us that's
very positive but also making sure that
we're able to explain what are the
problems with the north liner protocol
what is it we want to see in terms of
finding a way through this we want to
get an agreement with the eu but that
does require the eu to show some
pragmatism and some flexibility for the
benefit of the people of northern
ireland but biden
has more or less said he would veto any
deal until and unless and until there is
agreement on the protocol which
presumably would involve agreement uh by
the nationalists as well as the
unionists well a couple of these are
actual so first of all to be fair to the
president's not exactly what he has said
what the u.s is saying what well no i
wouldn't i'm not sure i'd entirely agree
with that what he has said and what the
u.s has consistently said is they want
to see an outcome agreed between the
parties and that respects the good
friday group that's exactly where the uk
government is you're quite right this is
an important factor this is something
that's got to work for the whole
community of northern ireland both the
national community and the unionist
community that's what we want to achieve
and let's also be very clear what often
gets missed in this discussion is the
problems with the protocol affect all of
the community in northern ireland
michelle o'neill uh who was deputy first
minister the lead sinn fein
representative in northern ireland
herself has said there are problems with
the protocol we want to get results so
this is not just an issue for unionism
if you can't get access to the products
you need to get access to as a consumer
or as a business in northern ireland
which is currently the case that affects
everybody and that's why we're seeing
one of the examples of this is the
problems the jewish community are having
so this is not just something about
unionism this is something we need to
resolve for everybody in northern
ireland by the way you've written an
article on friday which basically said
uh ask challenger unionists
to accept that if elections in may
uh result in a situation where the first
minister is from sinthane that they
would accept the post of
deputy first minister um
what are you going to do if they say no
because they haven't given you any
reassurances have they well
none of them are giving your insurance
is about anything in the head of the
election i think the very quote that uh
the politicians have given is they're
not commenting on what the outcome of
election may be before an election as a
politician i understand that but look
i'll be very clear about this as i was
last summer when she and fame were
trying to bring down the executive i
don't think the people in northern
ireland want to tolerate or are happy
with anybody threatening the
institutions of stormont that is part of
the group friday agreement it's how we
ensure we have good government in
northern ireland that devolved authority
to deliver on the issues like health and
education that need so much reform and
work in northern ireland we'll support
the executive to do that we want to see
a functioning executive all the parties
working together to do that all right
now on friday evening prime minister
received a questionnaire from metropolis
police on his alleged involvement in
many parties that took place in downing
street um now you just talked about the
important issues that face people in
norman face people all over
this country and most people would say
that every second of the prime
minister's attention should be on those
big issues
energy the ukraine
ukraine the crisis in the health service
the economy but it won't be
while he's answering questionnaires how
much longer are you going to let this go
on well obviously the
investigation into this is a matter for
the police i'm not going to put time
frames on them they've got to be able to
do their job independently autonomously
and and see that through we've all been
very clear about that but i have to say
in the dealings i've had with the prime
minister he's absolutely focused on the
job in hand about what's what he's doing
for the british people whether it's on
the conversations i've had with him on
northern ireland be it the protocol or
the situation with the executive and i
know from cabinet meetings i was
attending most of the cabinet meeting
last week before i flew to the u.s his
work and his focus on our health service
and as you say on the issues with russia
and the ukraine yeah but as far as i
know prime minister minister's human and
it would be ridiculous to imagine that
he's not thinking about that uh as ian
duncan smith says in one papers this
morning i'm paraphrasing here that if he
is fined by the police he is toast and
he has to go well i haven't seen ian's
comments this morning but i have to say
what i have seen is a prime minister who
is absolutely focused and dedicated to
working on the issues that are affecting
people across the united kingdom whether
it's the cost of living whether it's the
issues as i say with russia and
obviously in my uh portfolio of the
issues with north korea he is somebody
who is absolutely focused on that he
works day and night to make sure we are
delivering a country that becomes even
better for people so he's paying no
attention to the fact that a former
prime minister john major says he had
shredded the uk's reputation another
former prime minister teresa may said
public had a right to expect their prime
minister to have read the rules
understand the meaning of the rules and
set an example by following the rules
are all those people wrong and they see
not even bothered about that
but no he's he will actually be very
very focused on the issues that matter
to all of us and look we are talking
about prime minister as foreign
secretary worked to bring the world
together when we had the strip-off
situation when we have the scriptural
situation sorry we've got a prime
minister who is now bringing the world
together in terms of how we do with
russian ukraine he's working within this
country about ch dealing with this
coveted
after problem we've got the crisis we're
seeing in the health service dealing
with the backlog of that dealing with
the issues that people care about our
energy costs they're what he's focused
on and that's absolutely right where he
should be focused okay because that's
what makes our country better well look
let me give one last go at this and this
is really a question to you and your
colleagues rather than the prime
minister um
you came into politics to support the
conservative cause national sovereignty
lower taxes
all freedom of the individual all of
that
every sunday you and your colleagues
have to come out and to try to explain
what the prime minister's socializing
means
is there any point
for you at which the great cause of
israeli and churchill and thatcher
becomes more important than loyalty to
this prime minister well i always enjoy
coming to talk to you on a sunday trevor
and your colleagues across the media so
i i would always be happy to come out
yeah we're fine do that so
we're a lot of people i know but
honestly there's no the reality what do
you have to say
can't do this this is this is killing
the cause i came into play trevor as i
said uh in a conversation with somebody
uh
at the end of last week i feel very very
fortunate to be in the uh to be honored
enough to be in a position serving in
the cabinet i've served as a government
minister under three prime ministers
when you ask by prime ministers to serve
your country i think it's an honor to be
able to do that my focus is and always
has been on what we're doing for the
people of our country what i do for the
people of my constituency and in this
world obviously the people of northern
ireland i think it's right that we're
focused on that and i have to say as i
said to a few moments ago my experiences
that's what the prime minister's focused
on and that's why he has my absolute 100
plus loyalty look i think this is a
prime minister who's doing the right
things for our country he's got the big
decisions right i think he'll fight and
he will win as a result of that the next
general election all right well let's
deal with a couple of the real world
problems you're facing i mean this this
week um the resignation of crested dick
uh commission uh of the met appears to
have taken the government by its
surprise and for you it must be
somewhat alarming because she's one of
the key people in the fight against
terrorism which is a
big priority for you um
mi5 says that the national threat level
from terrorism is substantial and
northern ireland related threat level is
severe
for your point of view how quickly
how quickly does a new commissioner have
to be in place well first just as a a
matter of fact i think it's important to
make the point obviously the policing of
terrorism in northern ireland is dealt
separately that's a matter for the ps
and i working with partners in northern
ireland rather than the metropolitan
police but all of the police forces work
together and obviously as an ex-security
minister the importance of the mets role
their national role in counter-terrorism
is hugely important and the teams who do
that work that i've always said i think
are the best in the world they're
absolutely phenomenal it is obviously
important that we give them the
stability of having their leadership
dealt with as quickly as possible i know
that's something that the homosexual
will be focused on doing but it's right
that we
give the space for the home secretary
and obviously consulting with the mayor
and others to make sure we get the right
person for that job but the home sector
will be dealing with that very soon uh
there are there's it's being reported uh
by some newspapers that um the home
secretary uh would like to
uh essentially cut the mayor out of that
decision-making can you
uh confirm or tell us whether that is
true or not well as far as that's just
rumors i think it's always best to avoid
getting involved with rumors i think the
commissioner ultimately is working with
and for the mayor that's obviously
what's led to the decision the rather
odd decision in some ways because as you
rightly say the mayor just a few months
ago extended cressida dick's
tenure as the as a commissioner for
london but look the focus will be on
getting the right person to succeed
crested a dick to take the metropolitan
police forward to put in the reforms
that we all need to see and deal with
some of the issues that the met has
faced recently and to continue ensuring
that the met can grow to be and and do
the work it does in particular in some
of those sensitive national areas is one
of the best if not arguably the best in
the world in the end does the government
think that uh the mayor's decision was a
good was a good one was it
was he right to withdraw his confidence
well i i say i don't know the details of
um of why sadiq khan having just very
recently um extended kresadek's uh uh
tenure suddenly decided to uh withdraw
his comments in i absolutely respect
cressida's uh decision based on the
conversation we have within that
decision she's had to make i think the
focus has to now be on the fact that we
want to see the met moving forward there
are there is work to do it's a big
organization the largest police force in
the united kingdom and to get the
leadership in there that means it can go
forward and continue to develop and
change as it needs to to deal with the
issues he's had but also to deal with
the issues of uh policing on both the
national and the london scale that the
mayor has to deal with in the years
ahead